gotta give a shout out to Walsh Walsh
had a magnificent performance yesterday
over here in Tennessee at the Tennessee
State Capitol he uh he showed up to talk
about it was there was a bill that was
up about transgenderism and Walsh Walsh
just showed up he's a citizen of
Nashville and the the Democrats thought
that they could entrap him they thought
that they could own Matt Walsh with
facts and logic did not turn out well
for them
so I'm curious if 16 is uh a uh an adult
in your view why is this bill have the
minor defined as 18.
yeah that's that's a hit piece you took
from Media Matters uh from something
when I was a radio host uh 13 14 years
ago in my early 20s uh it's also not an
accurate reflection of what I actually
said I was talking about
uh the fact that people tended to marry
young historically and that's all that
that was about
um
how does that relate to this
subject
just curious your definition of if you
feel like people are adults of 16 should
people are adults at 18. but actually
they're your your brain is not fully
developed until you're 25.
so we should be having a conversation
about whether we should even be doing
these surgeries to people at 18. but
certainly before 18 it's it's absurd
I mean do you do you think that a 16
year old can meaningfully consent to
having their body parts removed
do you
no
we do not yeah we ask the questions it's
not
it's uh representative Hammer you are
recognized
absolutely devastating I I knew it was
going to go bad when the Democrat opened
his mouth because he was unsure of
himself he clearly as Walsh pointed out
he had this gotcha that he he got from
skimming and Media Matters or splc or
one of these left-wing hit organizations
and a hit job on Matt so you you once
you met you said a thing on the radio
about how 16 year olds used to get
married so and so you know like um so
what do you come on what do you think
about that and Walsh just absolutely
pile drives this poor this poor Democrat
state senator and he said so okay all
right well here's the explanation of the
line that you took out of context for
Media Matters um but just let's just
talk about the question here at the
hearing do you really think a 16 year
old can consent to having her body parts
removed
and the Democrats like
somebody help me and then the other the
other state senator or whoever this
person is we asked the questions here
yeah right maybe maybe you would be
better legislators Democrats if you had
answers as well as I know you got a lot
of questions you're confused about a lot
of things and Walsh went there and
provided pretty simple answers it's not
pretty basic stuff guys you don't need
to have a PhD in a Dr fauci white lab
coat and a stethoscope and you can just
you can have eyes
we have eyes and common sense to see the
boys and girls are different now this
hearing on big Tech
was absolutely a magnificent there's
much to say about it uh as pertains to
AOC she had some real real face plant
moments uh and it was the highlight of
of the uh of the hearing I'm going to
get to more of it tomorrow there's one
that I have to get to that was AOC
complaining about
the Republicans complaining about the
suppression of the hunter Biden laptop
story
New York Post had this alleged
information and was trying to publish it
without any corroboration without any
backup information they were trying to
publish it to Twitter Twitter did not
let them and now they were upset I
believe that political operatives who
sought to inject explosive
disinformation with the Washington Post
couldn't get away with it
and now they're livid and they want the
ability to do that again they want the
ability to inject this again so they've
dragged a social media platform here in
Congress they're weaponizing the use of
this committee so that they can do it
again
a whole hearing about a 24-hour hiccup
in a right-wing political operation that
is why we are here right now and it is
it it's just a an abuse of public
resources and abusive public time we
could be talking about health care we
could be talking about bringing down the
cost of prescription drugs we could be
talking about abortion rights Civil
Rights Voting Rights but instead we're
talking about Hunter Biden's half fake
laptop Story I mean this is an
embarrassment
there it is there it is so first of all
the factual claim she's making are not
true she says it was a half fake laptop
story it's not the hunter Biden laptop
story was completely 100 correct it was
not a right-wing political operation or
if the right wing obviously liked the
story because it exposed the truth about
the Biden family in a lot of crimes
but
it was a true story they got it
completely right
and the libs censored it anyway
what AOC just said there at the end
though
was her Hillary Clinton moment what she
said at the end there was her
Benghazi hearing what difference at this
point does it make what do who cares who
cares about the hunter Biden laptop
story that was the commentary
the commentary from the hearing was oh
are we wasting our time who cares about
the hunter Biden laptop story
uh you do
you guys obviously care you obviously
cared enough to instantly weaponize all
of big Tech to censor this story
not just on the public platforms
you you got big Tech to to prevent
people from privately messaging the
story
you thought this story was such a big
deal the story that's been proven 100
true even Hunter Biden admits it now
he's suing actually he's gonna wait a
second okay years later I'm willing to
admit that it was my laptop how did you
get it I'm going to start suing you for
it
you guys cared so much you thought that
this would be so detrimental to Biden's
presidential campaign polls after the
election showed that 12 percent of Biden
voters said had they known about the the
hunter Biden laptop story they would not
have voted for Joe Biden could have
could have been the difference between
Biden winning and losing
you guys cared that much and now you're
pretending that we're the ones who are
obsessed here this is what the libs do
all the time they say oh who cares about
transgender bathrooms
you do that's why you're trying to
change the bathrooms we conservatives
had no problem with men using the men's
room and women using the women's room
you're the one who made a big deal about
it you're the ones that started passing
all these crazy laws and showing up to
the state capitals and screaming and
crying and pretending that men are women
you you're the ones doing it
and conservatives should not fall for
this
do not fall for that that trick in that
trap
of saying well you guys if you if you
show any interest in this issue at all
you're you guys are obsessive it's your
Fanatics no
no we like the truth we care about the
truth you're the one starting all of the
aggression in the culture worth and now
you got caught we got you dead to rights
lady
at the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member at dailywire.com Knowles use code
Knowles at checkout for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign